Michael Myers you can shoot him six
times you can even make six terrible
sequels but Michael Myers will never die
Halloween is back welcome back to things
you missed today we're taking a look at
the trailer for Halloween I'm gonna be
breaking the down shot by shot for you
and pulling out all those juicy things
you missed now when you watch the
trailer you'll notice something very
early on check out this clip we're here
to investigate a patron that killed
three innocent teenagers on Halloween in
1978 anyone who's seen the movies knows
that he's killed a bit more than three
people I mean probably only our boy dead
meat and it was the actual number but
what what's going on here what's the
deal with that well it was previously
believed that this movie takes place in
a forth or depending on your view
possibly v universe and that it would
branch off from the main timeline after
Halloween too however this trailer
claims that after being shot by dr.
Loomis in the original movie Michael was
captured and taken into captivity where
he spent the last 40 years
that means this movie takes place in a
timeline where none of these movies
happened so this is essentially a fresh
slate for the franchise that's not to
say it doesn't have some homage as to
other films hidden in the trailer though
so make sure you watch this whole video
to see all of those unfortunately for us
that new timeline means that we may have
to sit through yet another scene of the
characters finding out that Michael
Myers is invincible as we have
painstakingly had to do in pretty much
every movie that's essentially confirmed
when we see the older Laurie Strode
doing target practice in her backyard
and trying to stab him with a knife come
on Laurie you know better than this
notice the guy at the beginning says
that Michael killed three innocent
teenagers I mean are there really such
thing as innocent teenagers though but
he makes no mention of Michael killing
his sister at the age of six which is
what happens in the first scene of the
original 1978 Halloween in this movie
Laurie has a granddaughter and she has a
line that confirms that Michael is not
even related to her no it was not her
brother that's the main of people made
up so that might lead some people to
believe that the opening scene didn't
happen in this timeline but I think
they've just neglected to mention the
murder of Michael's older sister Judith
because we do see a sketch of dr. Loomis
in the police report and it's mentioned
that Michael was shot by his own
psychiatrist
I can't imagine why he'd have a
psychiatrist without those events taking
place in 1963 first it's also really the
only explanation as to why these kids in
2018 forty years after the fact know
about a murderer who only killed three
people all those years ago and to the
point that he's a household name and one
more thing in the whole idea of Laurie
and Michael not actually being siblings
my theory is that they're taking the
Halloween three approach to where this
takes place in a different universe
entirely but the other movies still
exist as fictional movies in this
universe so in this universe somebody
made a based on a true story movie or
book about the killer Michael Myers and
then the sequel started to come out and
then they were not so based on the true
story and that's where the idea of
Laurie and Michael being siblings may
have originated of course it's also
possible that they are really related
and Laurie just doesn't know it much
like in Rob Zombie's Halloween to here
we get to see the police reports from
that Halloween night all those years ago
and they do contain some nuggets I
thought you might be interested in
this is Laurie's injury report detailing
the slash across her right neck and
shoulder and bruising and contusions
around the neck
this is only on screen for less than
1/10 of a second but there's a
photograph of someone's hand and this
almost looks like a reflection of the
mask but I might just be reading too
much into it here we've got a large
knife evidence from the upstairs bedroom
which of course was labeled with the
date 10:31 78 then again only 1/10 of a
second they show off evidence photos of
the mask this photo was probably taken
after the fact because it looks like
nobody's wearing the mask and the
background here is some kind of tiled
area whereas at the end of Halloween
Michael ends up on the grass outside the
house this is most likely a photo of
Tommy Doyle the boy that Laurie was
babysitting on that fateful night but
behind that we get a little glimpse of
the police report text the only
interesting thing that I pulled from
that is the mention of deputy Miller who
as far as I know isn't an existing
character in the franchise so this may
be someone new who is ret conned into
the story other than that it just seems
to be a recount of the events of the og
Halloween another question who are these
people investigating Michael Myers and
why now why are they trying to get a
rise out of him by showing him the masks
okay I guess that's more than one
question but I think this guy could be a
disciple of dr. Loomis or in any event
the successor to dr. Loomis who goes in
the town and warns people about how
dangerous Michael is just as Loomis did
the films that he was in unlike his
predecessor however he doesn't seem to
have given up on his patient just yet
Laurie asked him if he believes in the
boogeyman he says no suggesting he might
not see Michael as a monster
like Laurie does the woman that he's
working with is documenting everything
using the audio recorder and her name
tag also gives us a couple of clues
first we see the name of the facility
Smiths Grove State Hospital the original
facility that Michael broke out of was
called Smith's Grove sanitarium so it's
likely the same place that just got a
name change some point along the line
you have to believe that if you can
break out once he can do it again this
chicks name is Dana Haines there is a
security guard named Haines at a
different Hospital known as grace
anderson sanitarium in halloween
resurrection but i doubt that's even a
reference seeing is how hated that movie
is it's just my job to point it out to
you though okay wait hold up hold up
okay this kids a ninja this kid's a
skeleton
what is this kid's supposed to be Busta
Rhymes but on a more serious note this
scene is a major throwback to the
original Halloween where Laurie walked
home from school with her two friends
but this time if Laurie's granddaughter
they just put this boba tea in the shot
so you can tell that this is the 2018
one Laurie is absolutely crazy in this
movie she's basically spent the last 40
years preparing for Michael and if you
read between the lines you can see
everyone's subtle condescending behavior
towards her even her own family treats
her like a nutcase the bus crashed
what bus crashed additionally the
neighborhood kids seem to have no
respect for her authority she's
basically turned her house into a
fortress with cameras sirens even a
secret bunker it looks like they're
setting up a classic old lady who cried
wolf scenario Laura's been freaking out
over the last 40 years about the return
of Michael Myers no not that return of
Michael Myers and basically when he does
really come back nobody's gonna take her
seriously this bathroom scene may be a
reference to the opening scene of h2o
where a woman is attacked by Michael and
a rest stop bathroom in this case it
looks like it's a gas station bathroom
and it looks like a mechanic also faces
the wrath of Michael Myers so it looks
like a lot of the deaths in this movie
will be callbacks to the other moments
in the franchise despite them not being
on this timeline and back to the
bathroom stall for one moment this
drawing on the stall really stands out
to me it looks like a dog wearing
sunglasses looking to the left but I
couldn't help but notice
you're erased part of it you've got the
cult of thorn symbol from Halloween four
five and six now do I think that this
cult will be making an appearance in
this movie no absolutely not it would
just be a fun little easter egg for the
fans of those movies let me know your
interpretation of the bathroom stall
drying in the comments though I already
found my most character this lady
wearing a Christmas sweater on Halloween
a lot of people were confused about this
scene where Laura shoots because she
thinks she sees Michael in the window of
this house somewhere comparing it to h2o
or Laurie has constant hallucinations of
Michael but if you slow it down it looks
like it's actually just a mirror that
she sees him through one thing that I
found creepy is that there's actually
somebody in the other room over here
watching this all go down and the
person's head immediately snaps toward
the room that Michaels in judging by the
lighting I'd say that the room with the
blue light is this room where there's
yet another reference this time to the
ghost scene from the first Halloween
where Michael where's the ghost sheet
over his head to try to trick Laura's
friend Linda into thinking that was her
boyfriend Bob in order to get her guard
down I do think that Laura's
granddaughter is gonna be the main
protagonist of this movie and it looks
like one of her friends is a babysitter
so don't be surprised if what goes down
in this movie is very similar to the
events of 40 years ago if you enjoyed
any of these things you missed feel free
to drop a like on this video let me know
in the comments who you think it's
crazier this Laurie or the Laurie from
Rob Zombie's Halloween films anyway if
you're new here I'm Susie I write and
narrate my own horror stories as well I
just came out with one called creepy
clown school lockdown - don't worry you
don't need to see the first one just go
ahead and give it a listen
okay last announcement if you're going
to VidCon come to my fan meetup on
Thursday the 21st at 5:30 p.m. in room
211 we're gonna be raffling off some
merch and there's gonna be some other
cool creators there as well okay with
that out of the way I think we're gonna
be talking a lot about this Halloween
movie so make sure you're subscribed to
Susie's world for new Horrors every week
ring that death bell for notifications
and I'll see you in the next one
assuming we both survive